our new series
unifying america highlights people who
are trying to cross the racial
and cultural divides that separate so
many americans
today two of country music's biggest
stars marin morris and luke combs
will have a conversation at the country
radio seminar
about how artists can help open up the
genre to diverse voices and make changes
for the better
this follows the industry's rebuke of
morgan wallen
who was suspended by his record label
after using a racial slur
and the industry's support of t.j
osborne of the brothers osborne
after he became the first openly gay
artist on a major country label
with the genre at a crossroads we spoke
to four artists
about the state of country music right
now
i gotta be honest when you told me you
wanted to talk about this
i'm nervous vince gill was hesitant
your intentions can be so good and then
you can just get
just ripped country music
has long avoided uncomfortable questions
about its history and diversity i think
most people perceive
that country music is extremely
conservative
and i'm not sure that that's true maybe
the audience might be predominantly
conservative
but i don't know what the artistry is i
don't know that the community is
so there's a rub in there gill is one of
the most distinguished members of that
community
with 21 grammys the most of any male
country artist do you think country
artists need to
to speak up more well it'd be nice
you know i mean and no matter what the
issue is to see tj osborne come out
i thought was spectacular what did you
think when you saw the news about morgan
wallen
uh it was just sad you know it was just
disappointing because i knew that
everybody was going to
you know massacre country music and
white america
when they make the argument well i hear
it in rap music all the time i hear it
and
i go have you not been paying attention
to the last three or four hundred years
how that word has been used by the white
community it's it's a derogatory just
dismissive and
hurtful it doesn't have a place wallen
is the latest white man to rule the
country charts
between 2014 and 2018 a recent study
found
84 of artists on billboard's year-end
chart
were men country music at the moment is
perceived
as a white man's genre sure
women in country music could make the
same claim to some degree
that black art is good that they haven't
been made to feel welcome
why is it so hard for for artists of
color
and women i don't get into countries i
wish i knew
you know because i i'm someone that
adores what they do yeah and i think we
would be better for it
marin morris is one of the too few women
to break through i think the only way
that we can really
move forward is by deconstructing
our view of what the genre is built on
and acknowledging the fact that at its
roots
is racism and cultural appropriation and
completely destroying that mentality
going forward
morris and her husband singer-songwriter
ryan hurd
were quick to condemn morgan wallen who
recorded
heard song heartless i don't want to
seem like we're piling on morgan
but there's no place for that word
morgan is a symptom of a much bigger
disease of what our genre is right now
they were encouraged when hundreds of
radio stations took
wallen's music off the air and when
their friend
tj osborne of the grammy-nominated
brothers osborne
came out as gay he's out there alone on
this i mean as a major artist
in country music yeah i hope he doesn't
feel that way
he is such an amazing human and it takes
so much
strength to make that statement in our
genre and i think that like
you're seeing a lot of these little
moments add up to something really big
yeah the world is looking at us right
now people are starting to speak up
we're not protecting our own with this
wall of silence
because we're afraid we might be
cancelled next
it's like no we're all becoming more
accountable when morris won
female vocalist of the year at the cmas
in november
she used the moment to highlight black
artists
among them reecy palmer when palmer
scored a hit with
country girl in 2007 she was the first
african-american woman
to crack the charts in 20 years
why did you want to be part of an
industry that was
not especially welcoming to people of
color or to women
i knew in the very beginning that there
weren't a lot of people that looked like
me
and i knew that that was gonna be a
mountain
that i was gonna have to climb but i
love the music
i love the songwriting i love the
storytelling the way it makes me feel
yeah just i'm a fan on some level it's
got to be heartbreaking
to be a fan of something and then find
they won't let you in the club
it's heartbreaking i've been turned away
at my own shows
trying to get on stage and a security
guard wasn't going to let me get on
because he was like who are you and i
was like i'm recep
they're calling my name right now palmer
now hosts the color me country show on
apple music
that celebrates artists of color it's
my contribution to the reckoning or the
change that i want to see in nashville
do you see a real self-examination going
on i think in some sectors yes
but we'll see we'll see in hiring
practices we'll see
in signings we'll see in how the charts
look
that will tell the tale hmm yeah is
country music
ready for this conversation yes
i mean the thing is it's like they're
gonna have to be
because there's an influx of artists of
color
and it's time and vince gill
who was nervous about that conversation
at the end
offered up a song it comes he'd only
recently
finished 400 years of history
couldn't be more wrong
a reckoning's coming
gil calls it march on march on
i came here in shackles picked the
cotton
in chains that's the sin of my people
and i carry that shame
god knows you must be weary you've been
dreaming
so long you built this country
so much hear the full
song the full full march on march on by
vince gill
uh and our interview is more of our
interviews you can go to cbs this
morning on twitter
instagram facebook or youtube
we also want to note that despite the
backlash morgan wallin's album remains
number one on the billboard
chart and has been now for five straight
weeks we'll be watching today's virtual
uh seminar with mary morris and luke
combs who has been criticized for his
pa use in the past of the confederate
flag we'll see if he addresses that
today so
morgan wallin to your point his song is
number one but he's apologized and said
please don't support me in this i was
that's right
yeah i like that he's sending that
message i like what reese
not like but when reecey palmer said she
can't even get on her own state she
couldn't you know
we always keep saying cancel culture
guys and i think maybe we should think
about accountability culture
there are cases of cancer culture but in
this case in this particular story
to me it's more about accountability
that's a beautiful point yeah and if you
want to get to the question of why this
is happening which vince gill said he
couldn't answer
you need to talk to reecey palmer
because when when she put out country
girl
the label actually told her to change
the lyrics because she mentioned in the
beginning that she was black
and in the end she doesn't and so there
is there is a form of prejudice in there
either it's either the labels or the
label assuming their audience has it
and and and it's got to be addressed by
mary morris the world is watching
the world because said he couldn't say
why but then he wrote that song that's
right